Carmichael: Is that Niko's special chair?
[heavy thud]
Spencer: Chronos: the broken computer.
Sp: We suspect it's a motherboard issue.
Wren: Well, maybe that'll work.
W: [clapping]
W: Previously I tried the helmet technique because I'd actually tried doing the clap method before,
[Sam playing guitar]
W: ...which is a sound syncing point, and it didn't work.
W: But I think I might've done something wrong in post, so I'm trying it again.
W: Thought about maybe, like, you know, the classic dial-up modems where it's like,
W: [dial-up modem imitation]
Men In Black II, Barry Sonnenfield
Agent J: [beatbox communication]
W: [dial-up modem imitation]
Alien: [beatbox communication]
W: Another thing you could do is, you can take the whole thing and twist it in a circle, and it'll sync like that.
W: I'm gonna go do another test outside.
[tripod clanking]
W: [worried groan]
[camera rig thudding]
W: We will get there someday, and by someday, I mean -
W: ...day after tomorrow, because that's when we have to film.
Freddie: I base my passwords on how rad it is to type them.
Niko: [laughing]
N: You don't do, like, you don't draw a picture? Like -
N: [whooshing noises]
Sam: Beautiful.
F: [laughing]
F: Clean up your desktop, bro. There's so much stuff in here!
N: I don't know -
F: Open this one, open this one.
F, N: [laughing]
F: What about this one?
F: You're just looking at suit JPEGs all day?
F: Wait, "Ripped Baby"?
N: Oh, yeah. There you go, that's what it's all for.
F, N: [laughing]
F: This is the VapeBlast 2014 Cloud Competition Finals.
Video: ...kind of like the X Games, or what skateboarding was 20 years ago.
F: [spluttering]
N: [laughing]
[Sam playing guitar]
N: Whoa!
N: [laughing]
F: Hold up.
F: Are you sponsored, bro?
W: Aw, wait!
W: Oh, man. Okay.
W: So, as you can see, we have the 360 rig up here now, so...
W: ...I'm gonna experiment getting a shot from up here.
W: Right here, you see that?
W: So, basically, this clip that should go here is actually right here.
W: You see how this is really smooth, and this is all brick?
C: Ohh, okay.
W: One of the walls has, like, very low detail, and it took that entire clip that should go here...
W: ...and projected it on the other side.
W: And I don't actually know how to manually change that.
W: Connect to this, turn on all at the same time, record all at the same time.
W: They're not all the same camera, so we're getting weird issues, 'cause they highly recommend using the exact same camera.
Sam: Let's do it.
[tripod clanking]
Sam: We're goin' to Little Tokes.
Sam: Gonna do a test shot.
Sam: See if this thing really works.
Monster Factory: Black Desert Online, Polygon
Griffin [heavily accented]: It will fit.
F, N: [laughing]
Justin: Just unnoticeable -
J, G: [surprised yells, indistinct]
F, N, Sam: [laughing, stamping feet]
N: He looks like a kid.
F: [laughing, stamping feet]
G [singsong]: I love his style, I wanna slide down his body like I'm on a Double dare Physical Challenge.
G: Wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute,
G [progressively more panicked]:
...wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute,
G [mock-horror]: Wait a minute!